ona I want to present to you some ideas
and then you can just tell me what you
think and then we'll start from there
that sounds great
so have you have you heard that's like
young dudes aren't dating for the most
part like they're not hooking up they're
virgins yes yeah mm-hmm well before we
even go anything why do you think that
is I mean I think a lot of it has to do
with dating apps and women having more
options now so yeah so I'll explain this
ID and I guess you agree yeah but we did
a segment on this before so just bear
with me if you've already seen it
basically before dating apps in social
media a college-age woman or or high
school whatever age is their dating pool
is limited
Isak college probably better idea it's
probably a better example their dating
pool is limited to the other college
students of the same age and around
their you know their peers but with
tinder now they can message a 30 year
old guy who lives 510 miles away yeah
and it was a car so when they both went
when this woman swipes right on a
twenty-year-old college dude in a 30
year old career guy she thinks they're
both attractive messages both of them
the 30 year old guy says I can pick you
up in my Honda Civic and we can go to
the lake or go see a movie and the
college guy says you want to hang out my
dorm with my with my dorm mates which
ones you gonna pick she's gonna pick the
guy who isn't in the dorm right so I
mean so you agree yeah but so but what
would you say that's materialism or do
you think it's just I think it's
biological explain what you mean like at
like women are driven to find a mate
whether or not you like it or not like
we're driven to be like okay who can
support us and you know men are driven
to be like okay well you know who's
gonna give us healthy children these are
biological impulses that we have so a
woman who's options are a guy with no
job drinks all the time you know parties
like his age it's age-appropriate you
should be doing that that stuff but you
know she had she had you know these that
was her pool and now she has men who are
have jobs and money and houses and are
ready to to do that to you know to be
who she is biologically driven to want
to be and so she's gonna choose that
unless she's wanting to party to like
the dorm guy and not ready to settle
them
because there's there's some so III
think there's a mix between biological
and social yeah I don't think it's
purely one of the other mm-hmm I think
typically you'll find from like the
feminists it's all social constructs but
there was a study I just talked about
earlier I'm either one of my other
channels that when a woman gets a
promotion she is more likely to be
divorced to get divorced mhm
if a man gets a promotion there's no
change you think she gets divorced by
her like her saying I want to get
divorced now because I can support
myself is that the man saying I can't
live with you being more successful both
wife so in my opinion is I think
typically not always women a woman wants
a man who is of higher status than they
are yeah somebody who's capable strong
confident that they can look up to and
know if like you can rely on yourself as
a woman and then you know you have this
powerful benefit in this strong man
who's also providing you like a safety
net I guess yeah and then men want to
feel like protectors yes so you you flip
the dynamic if the woman gets a
promotion now the man feels inadequate
it's almost emasculation yeah and so I
know that it's it's funny you'll see a
lot of feminists will say something like
Oh boohoo the poor man you know it's
like it doesn't matter what you think
about it it matters that men feel this
way and they'll leave yeah and so then
you you literally with this promotion
you end up with women now feeling like
they're men isn't sufficient because
they're higher he's not providing them
any safety at all and then the man
feeling like they're not protecting
anybody yep so I mean like does that you
agree yeah I agree with that
I completely agree so what do you thinks
what do you think the future future is
gonna hold then if we keep and this is
Sweden by the way where this was study
was done like one of the most
egalitarian societies yeah so here's the
here's what we're seeing we're seeing
low birth rates people aren't getting
married anymore mm-hm they actually and
now we have with like the me2 movement
there's a backlash dating has become a
lot harder yes men are behaving
differently what's what's the future
then going to be I mean if you want to
look at the way that we kind of look at
social media at this point like oh if
you're not finding it you know find
another site maybe there needs to be
like a site for made for the 20 year
olds that are getting girlfriends
looking
and maybe there's a group of women who
aren't getting boyfriends that you know
like aren't feminists but you know
something like that so maybe make a make
an alternate site for these men and try
to that's gonna work though I think I
mean if if a 20 year old woman can
choose you know at even a 25 year old
guy who's gonna car in a job she's gonna
yeah and so then what happens is those
young men who are in college who aren't
forming relationships aren't seeing any
incentive to better themselves to become
a provider or protector so that's why
they become feminists instead well no
the Predators do right because they're
but but yeah a lot of them are probably
so desperate they'll say oh I'll just
say whatever you want
yeah but then women don't like that yeah
well I'll ask you let's get let's get
will make it a little personal would you
like a male feminist guy who just fawns
over you and does whatever you say I
would hate there you go and then what
ends up happening is these guys who are
like white knights neckbeard whatever
yeah I know I'm being a little you know
a little harsh but let just say these
guys then after a year of doing what the
movies told them to do are shocked to
find you are not attracted to them and
so then what happens then they I don't
know I could get angry get handsy and
then get called out and then we raise up
the clock yep
yeah so do I I don't I want to be very
delicate here otherwise all the
feminists in the world are gonna come
and try and bite my head off
mm-hmm but I have I've seen a lot of
rhetoric that women want egalitarian
relationships they want to be with equal
partners yeah but then everything we
actually see is not the case and it's
not the case mm-hmm how do you feel
about this what do you think
overwhelmingly women biologically want
stronger assertive men yes
because I think biological your impulse
is biologically outweigh your social
construct
I think it's nature versus nurture and
nature nature wins in the long run no
matter how that was right uh that was
one of the studies that I was reading of
their day as well that you have all
these feminists in San Francisco when
when asked said oh I want an equal
relationship and then when they're like
how's your that how do you date and like
oh well when I date its traditional
gender roles yes so what
the future then men art Manhattan
hooking up they're not dating it's bleak
yeah I mean we almost need to hit a
reset button what everything I kind of
feel like the apocalypse is gonna be
slow and boring mhm and this is one of
the ways it comes about yeah you've got
a generation now that are of men that
are being stunted because of all the
things we've just talked about yep
you've got an increasingly you know this
increasing push right there's that there
was a tweet from progressive the
insurance company we need to encourage
more I'm gonna be CEOs but if we if we
look at that other data that says that
as women get promotions they get they're
more likely to get divorced I think what
wind up seeing is as women make more and
more money they're less likely to be
attracted to the average guy more women
are in school in United States today
than men yep so it seems like if the
income averages for a college degree
versus a high school degree are true
we're gonna end up with a generation of
women who view almost all men as an act
as inadequate mhm and then you're gonna
have a bunch of men their age who never
had a relationship at all and are gonna
be stunted basement-dwelling neckbeards
mm-hmm seems pretty bad what happens
when they turn 30 do you think and then
they move into the role of the people
who stole the eligible women from them
no they have no experience with women so
so they'll just move into the basements
instead of into the right yeah so so
like for me um man I'm a couple weeks
away from being 34 mm-hmm but I grew up
at a time I was I was you know coming of
age when these social media platforms
were being built so I exploited all of
them yes I had a very normal teenage in
you know years and 20s and everything
dating hooking up partying all the good
stuff and I skateboarded all the time
and I was arrogant and cocky you know
just awful person all that and the
ladies loved it I'm exaggerating a
little bit but I mean they kind of did
and now I'm in my 30s and I can go on
dating apps and be like oh yeah yep you
got it and then these other guys who are
like 26 have no experience because guys
like me have dominated the dating apps
for the entire the entire time yep so
when they're 30 they don't they've never
dated before and they might if they've
tried to dating app and it didn't work
they probably are gonna want to go back
on it when there's
to try again dating apps are awful
anyway like for well it's like for women
it's just you just sit there and you
inundated with messages from literally
everyone and then guys go in and message
literally everyone yeah it's it's become
awful so for the I've basically walked
away from it just like it's trash but
there was a period where it was like I
don't know if you've seen the Family Guy
episode where quagmire discovers tinder
oh yes and he's like hunched over he's
like yeah right exactly right
Lord of the Rings mm-hmm so there was a
period where it was glorious and then
that everyone just got on board with it
everyone used it and now it's just a
waste but I'm kind of envisioning this
future now where I think one of the main
driving factors for what makes someone
successful and responsible is
pair-bonding mating you know like a
reason to desert to live to grow at
least it used to be and now I'm like I
mean there's hope because a lot of
people outgrow that the social justice
aspect that's kind of aiding in stunting
all these men like the women who are
super social just so eventually you're
gonna be like okay like I'm ready to
settle down now no you know what I
failed to factor in mm-hmm with this
hypothesis these 30-year old guys who
were you know stepped over because of
tinder and stuff yeah there's there
there are gonna be 20 year old women who
aren't gonna go for 40 year old guys I
mean they actually might though some of
them but then you're gonna have weird
women as a result yeah you're gonna have
30 year old guys who live in their
parents basement and you're gonna have
the next generation below them even
worse mm-hmm although it skips over and
like you know Generation Z or whatever
becomes more manly in response I don't
know I see a lot of women that are you
know a little like late 30s and stuff
they never settled down kind of got so
far into hookup culture and then just
likes oh crap like that's wrong it's my
shot yeah man Millennials you're in for
a world of hurt mm-hmm yeah I think
especially millennial women yeah they're
because there was a couple stories that
I was reading a while ago this one got
me in a lot of trouble mm-hmm 30-year
old career women are having trouble
finding
I remember yeah this is so much fun yeah
it was trouble I do air cross because I
was laughing the whole time it was
awesome I'm like look at all these
sweets are so mad and I'm like what are
you mad at me for this is the story this
is the day I to make it up
uh-huh and like I'm pretty tepid I'm not
like trying to be mean mmm-hmm but yeah
these thirty old women I realized well
they take faxes endorsements and of
course in fact oh yeah being an
endorsement it's certainly coming from
my opinion that I read this uh-huh but
they but yeah they're starting to have a
rude awakening uh-huh that they're
thirty yeah and thirty year old men are
going for twenty year olds yeah but like
that was always the case you know yeah
they always like younger women and
younger women like older men yeah there
was a video by these two comedians and
it was like they're singing mm-hmm and
it's two women yeah and they're singing
about like being 29 and how like
everything's great life is good and then
she's like and now I'm turning 30 and
then she just art screaming everyone's
gone what's happening where all the men
uh-huh yeah that's that's gonna happen
yes so what's the future then are we
gonna sit in like pods and go to virtual
reality and just never date and make up
fake people to hook up with unlike the
sims I think it's gonna I think we're in
for a divided nation and I don't know if
it's gonna be like a civil war or if
it's gonna be a secession like I can't
tell you but really are two very aiding
different in general I mean this this
goes into the dating right there are
just two very different types of people
in this world there are right now in
America there are the people who pour
milk on themselves up Bernie Sanders
rallies look yeah and then there's the
people who just want to settle down make
a life stay home with their kids but I
think that's most people yeah a lot of
people are like that you don't you know
there's like radical and then there's
moderate no I actually think I just
start something I started thinking this
mm-hmm
the problems we're talking about our
city problems they're not rural problems
so rural people like if you if you if
you live outside of a big say if you're
in a rural area and you don't go to one
of these big universities or state
universities and you work a trade yeah
you've got your community your community
is gonna keep doing its thing now
economics could play a big role next a
lot of these towns are falling apart
yeah but if with Trump's
while stirring the economy then the
cities are the ones in trouble where
these weird dating things are happening
and the women aren't getting are you
having cats you know they're buying a
bunch of cats and they're like live and
I mean it literally like I know cat lady
wasn't meant to be like an exaggeration
and it's not anymore
look on look on Instagram man it's like
they're a bunch of feminist writers
mm-hmm
I kid you not cat accounts like you know
people ask me why I won't start an
account for my cat Figaro and well this
might have something to do with it you
don't want to be a cat lady you can he
can share my account it's like small
animals are replacing the the dopamine
release you got from having babies yes
so now we've just replaced you know
eunuch animals instead of children yeah
but it's mostly big cities yeah you look
at like you know rural areas they're
still having bigger families in fact in
there was research done in the 2000s
that conservatives were having more kids
and liberals weren't ya today it's
reflected in the generation Z being
slightly more conservative yeah so if
this trend remains true I think the
population will kind of go down hmm
you're gonna end up with a bunch of
urban and suburban you know weirdo guys
and women and a lot of it was the me
culture cuz that was right people want
to extend their childhoods instead of
you know growing up getting a job and it
was just a generation of you know
millennial late millennial Oh slightly
early Gen Z I guess it's like the 90s
and I guess babies kind of for them not
to offend any 90's babies you guys know
what you are but yeah and so was a
generation like that that kind of
decided well I can't have babies if I
want to extend my childhood so then that
came down I can't possibly have babies
because of climate change he's right
which is nonsense
no but I do think it's crazy that I'm
about to be 34 and I have no family cuz
my dad had two kids by the time he was
27 yeah and I'm like man you know what
you know the problem is though it's
definitely not me mm-hmm I think it's to
everybody else yeah so like when it
comes to the women that I've been in
relationships with they've so one
relationship I was in was
woman had a career and so we never saw
each other and she's like I'm not giving
up my cream like well I'm certainly not
yeah and then some other women are like
I want to go adventure and do my thing
I'm like I'm all about freedom and
liberty so you do your thing I guess
mm-hmm and the only option I really have
is to be like no you must be the wife
and like that's not me yep
so I haven't found so you gotta find
somebody who wants to you know start a
family and be maybe a stay-at-home
mother you know here's here's that
here's the challenge with that mm-hmm
my my perspective personality what I
find attractive we're all based on
liberal urban sensibilities yeah and so
most of the women in that space are
going to be fiercely independent
careerists and not necessarily
compatible mm-hmm so you know over the
past several years I've been you know
increasingly successful I have no
problem and no concerns about starting a
family whenever I need to
mm-hmm but most of the women that you
know I have been with are like can't
career yep and so there have been some
who are like nearly 40 and I'm like
[Music]
that's no offense I'm just saying like
40 old women are lovely okay well that's
the issue isn't isn't them being 40 it's
the difference in my age to their age
and where I am in my life and the same
is true with younger women too so I
could certainly find like a younger
woman who's like I just wanna like but
we weird you know I mean there's there's
biology that comes into play too there
if you're looking to start a family and
you know she's already in her 40s and
there could be some trouble and that
could be hard and that might not fit
your your what you want in your life
yep you know and so and that's that's
entirely true that's biology and I say
this I'm in my 30s I'm getting there so
you know it's it's understandable and
yes it's okay I think we're doomed hmm
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we're live
Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and
if you want to catch the full recorded
podcast which doesn't appear in these
clips make sure you join by clicking the
button down below become a member and
then go to the community tab of this
YouTube channel and you can see all of
our full episodes don't forget to like
share and subscribe if you want to get
more clips like this thanks for hanging
out and we will see you all in the next
show
you